you can refuse this swab you can refuse
a breathalyzer you can refuse to
participate in a field sobriety test you
can refuse to answer questions now law
enforcement doesn't like this advice but
we do still have Constitution hi I'm
Tracy Oppenheimer freeze and TV and I'm
here with the turning mark Gallagher to
discuss the latest addition to LAPD's
arsenal saliva swabs that test for drug
use at DUI checkpoints mark thanks for
sitting down with us thanks for having
me
so these swabs are supposed to detect
illegal substances in your system can
you talk about how they work and what
they're looking for well a swab is
somewhat similar to a blood draw and
that it's going to be able to analyze
what's in someone's body the limitation
of course though is it doesn't tell us
when they took it or how much they took
and how is it affecting their ability to
drive the vehicle and that's really what
we need to know to know whether or not
the person is a safety risk on the road
the science just isn't there yet can
these even be effective that's the
million-dollar question and we don't
have an answer there toxicologist the
experts who study from the effects of
alcohol and drugs in our body will tell
us that marijuana in particular is a
very difficult drug for them to
determine whether or not someone's under
the influence or can safely operate a
motor vehicle even if they have a full
lab of blood information it's difficult
to tell how long it's been since the
user has smoked it's difficult to tell
how it's affecting their ability to
drive what was the impetus for getting
these swabs out in the field I would
guess we're dealing with some anecdotal
evidence just the police in the field
coming across marijuana much more than
they did before with the rise of
medicinal marijuana as well as more
frequent use of recreational marijuana
police are simply coming in contact with
people that have marijuana in the car
the smell of marijuana appear to be
under the influence of marijuana more
than they ever have before
and they obviously want to do something
to prevent the safety risk recently for
the Supreme Court of the United States
issued a ruling clarifying when they can
force blood from a driver and whether or
not that blood can be used in a court
proceeding and I think that that
combined with the change in technology
is what's moving LAPD to want to try a
swab
as opposed to a blood draw so you don't
think that precedent from blood draws
will carry over to swabs I think that
when this issue finally comes before the
court and it will there's going to be a
case where someone's going to have been
swab and they're going to challenge it
and it's going to go all the way up and
the judge is going to have to decide was
this legal or not you know is this valid
test is this constitutional and I think
when they do that they'll look at the
law on blood draws because they'll
they'll make an analogy to it and say
yeah this is similar but they don't
necessarily have to reach the same
conclusion there are some differences
one could argue that a swab is not as
invasive as a needle you know we're not
puncturing the skin we're not sticking a
needle in someone we're taking a swab
but on the other side you can easily
argue that it still is invasive and it's
a violation of your privacy we're taking
your own something from your body
something that's very personal to you
without your consent without a warrant
so if you are stopped just give our
audience some advice should they decline
the test how should they decline the
test in order to preserve their rights
absolutely decline the test right now
under California law if you are stopped
at a checkpoint or any type of DUI
situation you are not required to give
any tests before arrest so you can
refuse this swab you can refuse a
breathalyzer you can refuse to
participate in a field sobriety test you
can refuse to answer questions now law
enforcement doesn't like this advice but
we do still have Constitution and under
the fourth fifth and sixth amendments
you have a right to remain silent you
have a right to a lawyer and you have a
right against unreasonable search and
seizure so you have to be careful about
when you're in this environment to not
feel coerced you have to be conscious of
where you are and remember your rights
if you do stand your ground are there
any potential ramifications for saying
no can they take your license away yes
you can be punished if you do not give a
breath blood or urine sample post-arrest
so if you are stopped and arrested under
suspicion of DUI alcohol or drugs once
the arrest takes place you have to
choose one of those tests and if you
don't you will face automatic penalties
you'll lose your driver's license right
now on a first-time it's a one
penalty so you can deny the tests before
they arrest you and would they have to
come back with a warrant in order to
continue exactly and the only exception
to that is if you're under 21 if you're
under 21 you cannot deny the
breathalyzer pre-arrest
which is an interesting wrinkle and I
know some people watching this might be
under 21 so if you're under 21 and you
refuse the breathalyzer pre-arrest you
will face the penalties of the DMV they
won't have any problems in court but you
will have those problems at the DMV
no one wants unsafe drivers behind the
wheel if these swabs are in a proper way
to test that to combat that do you think
there is a better means out there are we
just still searching so I doubt they're
gonna invent the perfect machine to
detect ultimately what it really comes
down to is good police work if they do
it properly they shouldn't have a hard
time showing who's dangerous and who's
not and we'll also have technology so
it's very easy to video someone these
days every police car has a dashcam
video every officer has an audio
recorder so if someone's truly under the
influence it shouldn't be that hard to
document that they're unsafe to drive so
relying on forced blood draws relying on
a swab that's unconstitutional relying
on trying to coerce people into doing
these things really is it necessary if
someone's truly dangerous document it
present it to a jury you're not gonna
have a hard time convicting with
legalization on the horizon already
legal in Colorado do you think that
we'll see more of these potential abuses
along with that I think so I think some
of the changes we'll see first will be
in the implied consent laws so we may
see the suave added to the list of
things that you're impliedly consenting
to by having a driver's license because
those laws are very easy to change we're
talking about administrative privilege
your driver's license they simply pass
the statute and we're good we don't have
this difficult constitutional analysis
we have with the Fourth Amendment
warrants forcible police activity that's
going to be a little trickier and I
think that's going to take longer to
play out and I'm curious to see where it
goes but the administrative changes I
think we'll see very soon well mark
thank you again for coming in and
into us thanks for having me for reason
TV I'm Tracy Oppenheimer